Jonas it comes dead doesn't thing of the
past the traditional sitcom has changed
radically over the last few years a few
years ago it was thought that the sitcom
form and basically died and reality
programming had taken over then they
found it it hadn't died it just took on
a little bit different form now to
understand sitcom sitcom is probably the
most underestimated of all story forms
it's actually quite complicated you have
to tell a complete story and it has to
be funny in approximately 22 minutes the
requirement of the writer to understand
their form their structure is incredible
there and it is one of the most dense of
all story forms we don't think of it
that way because we're laughing right
this is a comedy and it's often they're
very stupid kind of character so we
think well we don't have we don't you
know have great respect for this form at
least a lot of people don't but in fact
it is a very challenging form now the
sitcom form just like TV drama has a
number of genres that make it up now the
traditional sitcom is the family sitcom
and that goes all the way back to the
50s with you know father knows best and
Donna Reed and so on and you had that
classic nuclear family and what to
sitcom then showed us was family comedy
and it was something that everybody in
the audience could relate to and a lot
of times they would watch it as a family
now over the years we've then broken
into different kinds of sitcoms and
again like TV drama each of them steps
out in a very different way there are
different story beats for each of these
different kinds of sitcom so now besides
the family
come we have us the single sitcom we
have the anti sitcom we have the serious
sitcom a show like girls would be an
example of that so what what's what's
happening then is the forum is
diversified and that puts a greater
challenge on the writer because you have
to be clear what kind of sitcom are your
writing how does it step out and does
this particular show change the sitcom
for example girls takes the basis sitcom
form and it turns it on its head every
single beat of the sitcom is done in
essentially the opposite way that it is
normally done and so this gives us
tremendous benefits because this is a
quote sitcom that nobody's ever seen
before so right away it's got a
freshness to it but the way the
traditional sitcom worked was done for a
reason it allowed us to watch this
family for five plus seasons and again
we're talking 24 episodes on network 24
per year again a tremendous amount of
output so why do we have those beats in
the traditional sitcom because that's
how you create comedy plot over
five-plus years now so when you flip
those beats as they do want to show like
girls it gives you some benefits but you
have tremendous cost which means it
makes it much more difficult to create
plot over an entire season and over
multiple seasons this is the single
biggest problem i see that girls has is
it is as great deal of difficulty
creating standard comedy clock
you